hey youtubers is Charlie so there's a
lot of crazy stuff happening on the Game
of Thrones set as you can see spongebob
with Daenerys and Dora they explore no
idea what the hell's going on so this is
going to be my thoughts on some of the
spoilers coming from the set so I'll
address the stuff that I think is true
the stuff that I don't think is true
because I think there is some bull crap
so here we go for those of you wondering
you know what the hell is going on with
this picture Emilia Clarke had her
birthday while they were filming so they
just did a bunch of stuff with the Game
of Thrones people so they're just having
a little bit of fun but for those of you
asking me about the supposed plot lake
like supposedly the entire plot late for
season seven so the thing is is that
it's so early in their filming that it
almost sounds ridiculous that the entire
plot would have leaked so really the
only thing you can count on is the law
of the internet pics or it didn't happen
so there have been a lot of pictures
from the set so I'll talk a little bit
about those but in terms of like the
plot leaked that supposedly happened I
think that's less plausible there's just
a couple big things that happen during
that that are like so big that I think
that people really want to believe it
but I don't think that the entire plot
for season seven has leaked so there are
a couple big things that we know have to
happen in the next couple of seasons
Daenerys has to face Cersei and either
kill her or just drive her out of King's
Landing the Greyjoy's have to reclaim
the Iron Islands from euron greyjoy
and destroy his fleet in Jon Snow in The
Collected North has to deal with the
White Walkers although the rest of the
realm kind of has to deal with them too
so we know that those things have to
happen really like the stuff in between
is kind of up for grabs
depending on what the show is going to
change so you already have the bones of
a story so when someone leaks plot that
seems to like support points around that
you know people tend to believe it a
little bit more but what I'll do is I'll
talk about the stuff with the pigs
because we kind of know what the
directors list is and based on the
location that they're filming you can
kind of guess which episode they're
working on so recently the big thing is
that people who have been camping this
set the Watchers people people who have
been basically living at the Game of
Thrones set for the last couple of
months have seen a lot of
on snow and like you know northern
characters meeting with Daenerys as
characters and Daenerys herself at
Dragonstone or a place that looked just
like dragon stone so because we know
they had to meet eventually we can say
that yes like this moment will probably
be happening they're not trying to film
some fictitious scene in a way to throw
paparazzi off because the Walking Dead
does that this is a show that has to
deal with a lot of people camping the
set they did this big death scene with
the characters that people were trying
to spoil all summer so they had to do
all kinds of things and create fake
scenes to mislead paparazzi so it got
crazy
so because HBO had a big problem with
that same type of thing
last season people are wondering are
they having actors and duplicates stand
in places where they're not actually
going to be in episodes just to throw
off paparazzi but there's just been so
much of Jon Snow standing next to
Daenerys on the set that it's like okay
this is probably happening at some point
the other thing that it looks like is
they're talking to the director Matt
Shankman and he is doing episode 5 so we
can say that this stuff here is probably
going to be happening during episode 5
which falls after the halfway point
there are seven episodes in season seven
meaning that it seems like they're
meeting relatively early so if they're
meeting this early in the season what
does that say about what's happening
with the other characters because you
have Cersei who is like Daenerys as big
mission this season she's coming for the
Iron Throne so what I think they're
doing is they're trying to keep Lena
Headey around as long as possible
Cersei is a great character Lena Headey
is one of the best actresses on the show
so what it sounds like might happen is
the Lannister army won't go down quite
so easily so they're probably going to
be doing some Aegon the conquerer type
stuff if you haven't read the story of
how Aegon the conquerer conquered the
Seven Kingdoms he started a Dragonstone
like the Targaryen migrated with their
family and their dragons from old
Valyria stated Dragonstone for a while
until Aegon the conquerer generations
later conquered the Seven Kingdoms so
the other thing that we know is that
they're using certain sets to double for
two different locations so this place
here Daenerys is shipyards are also
doubling for the dragon pit in King's
Landing so you have like two completely
different types of scenes in different
episodes being filmed at the exact same
place from like slightly different ways
so you have to keep in mind that a lot
of times like when you see pictures from
this set just you know just because
they're all being filled in the same
location doesn't necessarily mean that
all those scenes are going to be
happening one right after the other or
even in the same episode but they still
do have quite a bit of filming left to
do so I think they've filmed at least
through episode 5 but what happens is is
they'll wait to film like the biggest
craziest action set-pieces till later
because it takes a lot more time to
organize they have to figure stuff out
so the stuff that is the easiest for
them to film they'll do first because
they can get that going a lot quicker so
just to address like the more ridiculous
supposed spoilers it's like a lot of
crazy stuff that's supposedly happening
later in the season everyone's been
asking will we ever see an ice dragon on
Game of Thrones so there are a lot of
people wondering if one of tenaris
dragons will fall in battle in the night
king will turn him into his own personal
mount like a raised white undead dragon
that he rides and uses to bring down the
wall which does sound kind of ridiculous
but it's super big so people are like oh
my god this would be amazing if it
happened but I tend to view stuff like
that with a little more skepticism
because here's the thing bran was
touched by the night king so I think the
night king wouldn't have any problem
crossing underneath the wall so I almost
think that he doesn't need to bring the
wall down completely in order to get his
army through but it would be like a big
action set piece for him to melt the
wall with an ice dragon so I think
that's why people want to believe it so
much because it'd be so crazy on-screen
so you can choose to believe it or not
I'm just gonna remain skeptical pics or
it didn't happen there's just a couple
things that I am pretty sure will happen
during season 7 so I'm more willing to
believe things that I hear that support
that like Cersei is still alive at the
end of the season meaning that Daenerys
is army isn't quite so badass
as we think it is I do think that one of
the Dragons will die by the end of the
series right now Daenerys seems
invincible that's usually when writers
pull the rug out from under characters
like Jamie just seemed like he was super
invincible for the first couple of
seasons till boom they just chopped his
hand right off and then I don't think
that all of Euron's boasting is
completely Hollow he actually is a
really good warrior in a really terrible
person so I do think that he's going to
be able to wreak some havoc on Daenerys
as fleet and then a lot of you are
asking about Jon Snow specifically you
know supposedly people have revealed
what his Targaryen name is in the name
that they picked would have to be like a
complete left turn from the books you
know like you talk about collapsing plot
lines and giving storylines to other
characters like giving Sansa a bunch of
fake Aria stuff where she has to get
married to Ramsay Bolton or giving
Gendry edrick storm storyline stuff if
spoilers are to be believed people think
that the show will eventually reveal Jon
Snow's Targaryen name to be Aegon which
I know a lot of you will scoff at you'll
be like hey wait a minute
that was the name of Rhaegar and elyes
baby that was killed by the mountain
during the final battle the sack of
King's Landing so in order for that
baby's name to be Aegon as well as Jon
Snow's name to be Aegon Rhaegar would
have had to been pulling some crazy
shenanigans because in the timeline of
Robert's rebellion the moment that they
found the dead baby Aegon along with
Elia and Rhaegar family happened way
before Ned traveled south to liberate
Lyanna stark from Rhaegar supposedly
liberate her because you know / the show
if these spoilers are to be believed
then Rhaegar would have had to have seen
this baby Aegon decided that he wasn't
the fulfillment of the prophecy gone and
had another baby with Lyanna Stark
quickly after that and also named him
Aegon so that just sounds really crazy I
still like the theory that Jon Snow's
Targaryen name is Jo Harris just a
little bit more but do be prepared for
the show to make dramatic left turns
from book plots in service of the actors
and the characters that it still has
alive right now but here's my question
for you you know like
just because there's a lot of ridiculous
stuff flying around we'll say like one
of the most ridiculous sounding things
do you think that the night king will
take down one of Daenerys dragons and
turn him into his personal mount it
sounds almost ridiculous that you want
to believe it but I'll just remind you
just be skeptical about anything you
hear that doesn't have pics attached so
until you see leaks of like behind the
scenes night king riding what looks like
a prosthetic dragon just take caution
with the stuff that you believe that's
coming from the set so I'll say it
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner
Fernando Omar you win a $20 Amazon gift
card be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there is a new
round of the giveaway that starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so like I said there's still a
couple of episodes that they have left
to film there's still a lot of filming
so they'll continue to be weird stuff
coming from the set so they'll be all
kinds of crazy stuff happening for the
rest of the year if they're any bonus
videos that you guys want me to do about
big questions that you have or or
storylines or characters from the books
just let me know in the comments and
I'll be posting my Walking Dead episode
2 video tonight after the episode airs
well you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my non-spoilery
Doctor Strange review and you can click
here for my Walking Dead episode 1 video
to get ready for tonight thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you